after shutting down a Manhattan Street
and dealing with reshoots just weeks
before release I Am Legend went from a
hopeless production stuck in development
Health to a global box office smash
though many may now associate the title
I Am Legend with Will Smith being the
last man on Earth this story far
predates its 2007 release or even Will
Smith's 1990s descent to movie star
status I Am Legend is based on the 1954
Richard Matheson novel of the same name
and is the third and most recent
adaptation of the book following the
release of the Omega Man in 1971
Hollywood spent years trying to develop
a new adaptation of Matheson's novel and
they got close to doing so in the 1990s
according to variety this 90s version of
I Am Legend was set to feature Arnold
Schwarzenegger navigating a
post-apocalyptic landscape Ridley Scott
was brought on to direct in what would
have been an epic first collaboration
between the two the project progressed
quite far along to the point that makeup
tests were done for the film's vampire
creatures sadly the production
eventually fell apart due to an
assortment of issues the most prominent
of which were budgetary concerns Scott
was struggling to achieve box office
hits in the mid-1990s and I am Legend is
a dark depressing story that's anything
but a sure thing for a film studio
looking to earn back profits Warner
Brothers halted the project so this
version of I Am Legend went cold though
disappointing for all involved in this
incarnation of the film it did pave the
way for a different I Am Legend to get
launched into the stratosphere a decade
later once Francis Lawrence's film
debuted in 2007 the long journey to
produce a new adaptation of Matheson's
classic finally came to a satisfying End
by the time 2005 rolled around I Am
Legend had been through the ringer not
only had Ridley Scott's version of the
film failed to come to fruition but
another Incarnation had also fizzled out
the 2002 version was supposed to be
directed by Michael Bay produced by
Arnold Schwarzenegger and star Will
Smith after a while it just seemed like
I Am Legend was doomed to be accursed
unmade Blockbuster
but Warner Brothers was determined to
get this production off the ground and
not let a potential star vehicle for
Smith go to waste so the studio pressed
on and Francis Lawrence became the
latest filmmaker to take a swing at the
property in September 2005. before his
work on The Hunger Games Lawrence didn't
have a lengthy feature film track record
as did the other directors previously
attached to I Am Legend but earlier that
same year he'd helmed Constantine for
Warner Brothers needless to say the
studio was very excited about his
prospects as an artist the plan was to
start filming in 2006 but given all the
false starts that I am Legend had faced
up to this point it would have been
understandable to greet this news with
skepticism amazingly though Lawrence did
end up directing the feature and for
this once tormented film that was
something of a miracle although
post-apocalyptic movies have been made
since the invention of Cinema the
subjects of these films often change
with the times to reflect the political
and social climate of the era the 2000s
saw a Resurgence of apocalyptic films
but viruses that turn humans into
terrifying creatures with the release of
movies like Resident Evil in 2002 and
the Dawn of the Dead remake in 2004. I
Am Legend rode that wave of interest to
massive box office profits but while it
may have been one of the most successful
post-apocalyptic movies ever it still
faced some competition from other 2000s
films in fact I Am Legend screenwriter
Kiva goldsman has discussed how Danny
Boyle's 2002 zombie flick 28 Days Later
proved influential on how he would
navigate the approach to a
post-apocalyptic World talking to
Entertainment Weekly goldsman notes how
he wanted to take on the script for I Am
Legend but it seemed like the existence
of 28 Days Later would stop I Am Legend
from happening since it would tread too
much familiar ground that's why he and
Lauren set out to differentiate I Am
Legend from Boyle's beloved future they
decided to make something that was more
about characters and emotions than
monsters and changed the setting from LA
to New York City in the end in this
moment of 2000's Global Cinema there was
plenty of room for two post-apocalyptic
Thrillers Will Smith has built his
career and iconic Persona through his
natural rapport with seemingly every
actor that he shared the screen with
whether it's Tommy Lee Jones and the Men
in Black movies Kevin James and hitch or
Martin Lawrence and bad boys Smith can
be compelling with anyone and everyone
including dogs as we see in I Am Legend
if you're planning a party or something
just tell me now
okay because you know I don't like
surprises and I swear I'll act surprised
this gift meant that I am Legend was a
unique challenge for Smith who plays the
last man on Earth unable to lean on that
entertaining chemistry he often Sparks
up with others talking to collider Smith
noted that part of how he prepared to
play this character so outside of his
comfort zone was by talking to people
who've experienced extreme cases of
isolation like former prisoners of war
and people who have been in solitary
confinement talking to them revealed
very specific details of the psychology
of isolated people Smith embraced the
absence of dialogue for much of the film
which allowed him to subtly communicate
a sense of one man doing his best to
defend himself both physically and
psychologically by accepting such brutal
qualities tied to this character Smith
was able to deliver a performance unlike
any other in his filmography while I Am
Legend used its share of green screen
and practically built sets the majority
of the movie was shot where the story of
this film adaptation takes place case
New York City you can't fake New York
the Montreal Toronto I don't care where
you go
New York is the is the best backdrop in
the world Barnard the general hustle and
bustle of America's most populous city
make it a logistical nightmare for any
movie to shoot there let alone one where
there's only supposed to be a single
human being left alive this required
sections of the city to be closed down
so the I Am Legend crew could film in
this location and make it look
appropriately sparse
as one can imagine this did not go off
without a hitch with Will Smith
recounting to the Los Angeles Times that
he encountered plenty of frustrated New
Yorkers whilst he was filming this
Blockbuster he joked people were not
happy that's the most middle fingers
I've ever gotten in my career though the
process encountered its fair share of
criticism and hurdles Francis Lawrence
remained committed to filming I Am
Legend on location including the
Brooklyn Bridge where he managed to
capture a lengthy and complicated set
piece the result is that the world of I
Am Legend has a tangible quality to it
rather than coming off as otherworldly
there is a haunting relatability to the
environments that the surviving
characters navigate all of the
challenges presented in filming a story
has sparse's I Am Legend in New York
City paid off handsomely with this kind
of quality ingrained into the movie
reshoots are common on films of any size
but they're especially prevalent in
Blockbusters sometimes you just don't
know how a movie is coming together
until you see it in the editing room you
usually such reshoots are done a few
months before release to allow enough
time for the post-production team to
work on these sequences it's rarer
though not unprecedented for a film of I
Am Legend stature to commence reshoots
just weeks away from its theatrical
release and that's just what this costly
production did with Outlets like slash
film reporting in mid-november 2007 that
Warner Brothers had just wrapped up
reshoots on I Am Legend which was set
for a December release at the time
rumors spread that the studio didn't
like the initial gloomy ending to the
movie and asked for reshoots of the
finale the original ending of I Am
Legend forced both Smith's protagonist
Richard as well as the audience to
question who the real monster is in this
story but this got swapped out for a
more generic showdown between good and
evil this newer more Hollywood ending
robbed I Am Legend of a compelling moral
ambiguity while the way it feels so
shoehorned into the story can also be
attributed to the fact that it was
executed during these incredibly last
minute reshoots I Am Legend was an
Undisputed hit at the box office but
critically the results were more mixed
there was Universal praise for Will
Smith's performance and how well he
carried so much of the film on his own
in addition to the well-realized
sparseness of a haunting
post-apocalyptic New York City landscape
however there were equally rampant
critiques over the conventional nature
of the finale and the heavy Reliance on
CGI to create the night Seeker Monsters
the latter complaint was even shared by
the director who discussed his feelings
in an interview while looking back on
the film talking to den of geek in 2011
Lawrence noted that he initially tried
to portray the night Seekers with humans
in Prosthetics but that approach didn't
translate to screen so he went to CGI
road instead but the CGI used to realize
these characters never looked quite
right which was the result of a
compressed post-production schedule
Lawrence did feel that with more time
dedicated to fine-tuning the CGI these
visual effects would have looked
satisfactory but in the Final Cut they
never looked quite right and Lawrence
noted to den of geek that at one of the
big downfalls for me with I Am Legend
personally was with the visual effects
he also observed that the scariest
scenes in I Am Legend were those that
took cues from the likes of alien and
kept everything shrouded in Shadows once
the creatures were totally visible the
suspense was lost even if I am Legend
didn't quite click together at least its
director could be open about these
shortcomings believe it or not I am
Legend wasn't just a box office hit in
its initial theatrical run it was a
record-breaking success the film managed
to open to 77 million dollars in its
first three days of domestic play
cementing it as the biggest opening
weekend ever for a December release at
the time it was also the biggest opening
weekend ever for a Will Smith title an
impressive feat given just how many
massive films he'd been associated with
during his career up to that point I'm
getting good in the years since I Am
Legend premiered it still stands as one
of Smith's biggest North American
openings only Suicide Squad in 2016 and
Aladdin in 2019 managed to score larger
returns domestically I am Legend's box
office Feats were all the more
impressive given that this wasn't a
sequel in a successful franchise in a
year where Shrek Pirates of the
Caribbean and Spider-Man all delivered
third installments I Am Legend was a
reminder that original films could Excel
financially once the dust settled I Am
Legend scored
256.3 million dollars in North America
that was enough to make it the sixth
biggest title of 2007 at the domestic
box office putting it ahead of big
sequels like The Bourne Ultimatum and
National Treasure Book of Secrets the
film performed even better globally and
took in 329.1 million dollars worldwide
which brought its total box office
profits to a whopping 585.5 million
dollars these accomplishments all made I
Am Legend truly legendary when it came
to box office performance in October
2014 deadline broke the news that Warner
Brothers was now moving forward on a
reboot of I Am Legend one based on an
unrelated spec script entitled a garden
at the end of the world the script which
was described as the Searchers told
through a Sci-Fi lens had enough
overlapping elements with I Am Legend to
make it work as a reboot of the 2007
film The Most Interesting wrinkle here
was the presence of Will Smith or rather
the lack thereof this new reboot was
being configured from the get-go to not
include him at the time Smith's
reluctance to do sequels Inspire The
Producers to opt for a new story with
different characters rather than try and
Court him the lack of Smith suggested
that this reboot would be going in
wildly different directions compared to
the original I Am Legend though
audiences would never get to know what
the plans were as the project ended up
fizzling out as well even though we may
have thought all hope was lost for an I
Am Legend sequel the Plucky one film
franchise refuses to die an I Am Legend
sequel was announced in 2022 starring
Smith once again alongside Michael B
Jordan
[Music]